In this lesson we're going to
cover a lot of ground.
We'll talk about choosing the right
UI patterns, laying out your screens,
working with graphics and
texts, and a whole lot more.
But before we get into all
those really fun things,
we'll first need to learn about one of
the core aspects of Android design.
That your designs must work on a lot
of often very different devices.
Android runs on all types of things
from tiny watches to phones and tablet's,
even to cars and TV's.
This variety can be daunting.
The good news is that Android has been
designed to handle this variety in
device types from day one.
The platform gives you a whole
bunch of tools and techniques for
handling different devices easily and
gracefully.
Your goal should be to create a single
app that runs across a range of devices
adapting the interface depending on
what device it's currently running on.
As we'll find out throughout the course,
optimizing the user experience across
a variety of device screens and
form factors isn't that difficult,
and can actually be pretty fun.
Let's start by talking about the screens
on all of these different devices.
At the end of the day, what good is
designing beautiful buttons, text, and
graphics unless you understand the
screens that it will be shown on, right?
When thinking about the variety
of screens your Apple run on,
it can be tempting to look
at the screen's resolution
as the number of pixels on the screen.
Screen resolution is a commonly
used spec when buying a device, but
it's actually not that useful
when designing for Android.
because thinking of screens in terms
of pixels ignores the notion of
physical size, which for
touch device is really really important.
When Android was first released,
there was a single
commercially available device.
The T-Mobile G1.
As a result, it was easy and
often common practice to design with
the resolution of this device in mind.
Mobile designers accustomed to IOS,
where there was only one form
factor to design for, would apply
that same practices to Android and
design assets for one or two flagship
devices with exact pixel sizes.
These designs would look horrible
when viewed in a device with
different proportions.
Android 1.6, Donut, introduced support
for more varied device types and
densities.
Recognizing that generating
pixel perfect assets for
every existing device doesn't scale and
that one would need
a systematic way to deal with assets
on different screens to better fit.